Transcriber: Yahya Mansour
المدقّق: Ghada Khalil
عندما كان عمري ثمانية شهور،
وفي الوقت الذي كنا ذاهبين فيه
إلى دار جدي أنا وعائلتي،
كان لا بد أن نمر بحاجز يسمى “حاجز حلميش”
المقام على أراضي قرية النبي صالح.
كان هناك عند ذاك الحاجز
قوة من جيش الاحتلال.
وعندما وصلنا إلى هناك،
سمعنا صوت جندي يقول:
“عبد الكريم، انزل من السيارة
وسّلم الفتاة لأمها“.
ومنذ ذلك اليوم وبعد واحد وعشرين عامًا،
ما زلت أنتظر عودة والدي
راكبًا نفس السيارة.
أقف أمامكم اليوم
وأنا رَند ابنة الأسير المعتقل
في سجون الاحتلال منذ واحد عشرين عامًا،
ابنة الأسير “عبد الكريم الريماوي”
أقف اليوم أمامكم وقد نشأت
على رسائل السجون.
الرسائل التي كانت تصل
بعد شهر أو شهرين من كتابتها،
ليس لأنهم كان يرسلونها بالحمام الزاجل،
بل لأننا محرومون من وصولها
في وقتها المناسب.
نشأت على هذه الرسائل التي كونت
علاقتي البريئة مع والدي خلال فترة اعتقاله.
لن أقول لكم أن مرحلة الطفولة مرت سريعًا؛
فهي لم تمر بهذا الشكل نهائيًا.
لقد مرت بتناقضات وفجوات مستمرة
منذ اليوم الأول من طفولتي وحتى نهايتها.
يومي الأول في المدرسة وخطواتي الأولى
ونجاحاتي والتحاقي بالثانوية العامة
وأعياد ميلادي،
كل هذه الأوقات كانت تَمر بشكل ناقص.
في أحد هذه الأوقات، في عيد ميلادي السادس
كان يصادف موعد الزيارة لأحد السجون.
ذهبت إلى الزيارة وقد عقدت النية
أن أخبرهم أن عمري ما زال خمس سنوات،
لأنه السن القانوني لإدخال الأبناء
لرؤية آبائهم الأسرى.
دخلت الغرفة التي يجتمع فيها كل الأسرى،
وصافحت كل المتواجدين.
وعندما كان الدور على والدي،
جاء الجندي وأخرجني من تلك الغرفة،
وقال لي: “لقد أتممتِ الست سنوات
ولا يسمح لك بالدخول إلى الغرفة“.
كانت طفولتي مليئة بعلامات الاستفهام:
أين أبي؟ لماذا والدي ليس هنا
بينما لدى الجميع آباء بجانبهم؟
لماذا كنت أستيقظ في الصباح
لألحق الحافلة
التي ستقلني إلى سجن النقب أو بئر السبع
أو عوفر أو ريمون أو نفحة؟
لماذا أنا؟
إن مرحلة الطفولة هذه
كانت طويلة، ووضعت على عاتقي حِمل كبير
كان متمثلٌ في كل رسالة أتلقاها من والدي
ادرسي بِجد يا رند لأنني أريدك
أن تكونين من المتفوقات.
وضعت طفولتي على كتفيَّ هذا الحمل الذي كان
في تزايد مستمر حتى وصلت للثانوية العامة،
حتى تخرجت من الثانوية بمُعدّل 92.4%.
هذا المُعدّل
(تصفيق)
أهلني هذا المعدل أن أتخصص في المجال
الذي طالما رأيته انعكاسًا لوالدي؛
انعكاسه في الجامعة وعلى مقاعد الدراسة،
بل وانعكاسه في الواجبات.
كان هذا التخصص في الإعلام،
الذي لم يستطع والدي إنهائه بسبب اعتقاله
في العام الأخير من دراسة هذا التخصص.
تمكنت ثلاث مرات أن أكون على لائحة الشرف
خلال تواجدي في الجامعة.
(تصفيق)
أنا أؤمن بأن الحق في التعليم هو حالة
من الاستمرارية، ليس فقط لأهل الأسير،
ولكن للأسير نفسه.
استطاع والدي بعد الانقطاع التام
عن الدراسة لمدة واحد وعشرين عامًا،
أن يحصل على درجة البكالوريوس
داخل سجون الاحتلال
واستلمت بنفسي هذه الشهادة منذ أسبوعين فقط.
(تصفيق)
قادتني كل هذه التفاصيل
إلى أن أكون قادرة على التطوع في حملة
“الحق في التعليم داخل الحرم الجامعي“.
كشفت لي هذه الحملة الكثير
من التفاصيل وعن تاريخ الجامعة
من خلال إغلاقات الاحتلال المستمرة لها،
حيث أُغلقت الجامعة خمس عشر مرة
بغرض إيقاف العملية التعليمية،
لكنها ظلت مستمرة بشكل أو بآخر.
وفي إحدى المرات،
كنت أقرأ في جزئية مكتوبة
على إحدى الأوراق كانت تقول:
“ليس من الجميل أن نرى بستانًا مغلقًا“،
وهكذا كانت الجامعة.
كانت حصيلة كل هذه السنوات
وكل هذا الحرمان وكل هذا الفَقد
أنني استطعت إنشاء مشروعي الخاص
في بداية العام الأول في جامعة “بيرزيت”.
كنت على يقين أن هذا المشروع سيكون رسالة
لكل أبناء الأسرى وأمهاتهم وزوجاتهم
ولكل الناس المحرومة من فقيد أو أسير
داخل سجون الاحتلال.
هذا المشروع اسمه مشروع “صَبِر”،
وهو عبارة عن زراعة الصباريات،
واستطعت أن أوصل الرسالة
التي تعبر عن كل الأسرى وكل عائلاتهم
بأنهم لا يزالون على قيد الحياة
رغم الحرمان والفقدان،
وأنهم يعيشون على خيوط من الأمل
رغم كل تلك التفاصيل.
في الختام، إن واحد وعشرون عامًا.
ربما تكون قليلة بالنسبة
للأشخاص الذين يسمعونني،
ولكن واحد وعشرين عامًا تساوي عمري.
شكرًا.